[Music]
Ahhhhh
[music] The
meat rubbed with herbs was slowly roasted at a low temperature
with feijoa mousse as a garnish.  Please give it a try
It's a fruit native to Central and South America.
It shows a side of ingredients that no one knew about
.
Blood sausage finely chopped into gree
It's a characteristic of mixing pig's blood with Hinatori's house that I just pulled out.
It's a fried rice with a rich flavor, such as
death
, not only the house, but also the death was extracted from the
chicks.  Sensei and total princess
Hina drinks,
I added my own sausage and floor well Ayonara
I'm obedient with ability like me and a disciple Ecstasy
Mareishi's item is also a perfect one that draws out 120% of the charm of the material  Wasn't it cyber?